as of guys my name is Jenna welcome back
to my game engine series so last time we
added textures to a batch renderer check
out that video if you haven't already
and between the two of us has been a
really really busy week so let's just
get on with it
one of the things that we actually
didn't do last time was the whole
rotation situation so we can't actually
render a rotated quad at the moment
without batch renderer this is still our
old path so how exactly do we get our
quads to rotate now before this was
really easy because we had this kind of
transformation matrix as a uniform and
we could just multiply it all in the
shader and everything was was good but
we can't do that anymore because we're
basically baking our vertex positions
straight in here and that's kind of it
we're not actually we don't have any
kind of transformation uniform if we
were to have one it would affect the
entire batch of geometry wouldn't just
be that individual quad so if we want
one certain quad to be rotated we have
to apply that transformation over here
on the CPU side instead of on the GPU in
the shader and it's fairly
straightforward to do that all we really
need to do is build up a transformation
matrix like we would out of like a
rotation matrix and maybe translation
and scale as well and then just multiply
that with every vertex so it's basically
doing exactly what our vertex shader
would be doing for every vertex it's
just that instead of happening on the
GPU in GLSL it's happening on the cpu
with C++ so let's get all that sorted
the first thing I want to do is
basically copy this entire draw quad
function so we still need the
appropriate texture index and all of
that stuff let's go ahead and copy
everything that we have here except for
the old path of course we'll come down
here this is the one that actually takes
in the texture let's do this one first
so I'll just basically override all of
this stuff we're not gonna leave the old
path we've got that in version history
anyway just in case but basically what
we need to do is figure out the position
the way that we've been doing this does
far has been just positioned or X plus
size of X that was kind of our scale
matrix so to speak and in our kind of
translation matrix is just this position
and that's it but we're going to switch
from that to actually using a
transformation matrix for all of our
draw quad functions now it's not
strictly speaking necessary to do this
because if the quad isn't rotated we can
easily just transform it
scale it using simple kind of addition
and subtraction potentially like we
don't have to like go through matrix
multiplications but if it's a give the
code being the same across all of our
drawing functions I'm actually going to
just make all of them deal with like
transformations now you could argue that
performance wise maybe this isn't the
best thing to do but until like someone
profiles it and maybe I'll profile it in
the future and we'll see what it's like
I'm not gonna change it back and I'm
just gonna kind of make it all the same
across the board because that's just
going to be easier I think for everyone
so in order to do that we need four
vertices to actually perform the
transformation on what I'll do first is
actually build up this transformation
matrix so we'll have this transform here
and again a transform is made up of a
translation or rotation and a scale so
we'll start by translating and I really
don't like this whole like GLM you know
situation here with it anyway I think
that in the future we might actually
wrap GLM with our own math library
because as time goes on this is getting
more and more annoying for me anyway we
have a vector E position here which is
perfect we've got our translation matrix
we'll multiply that with a rotation
matrix so we'll have GLM rotate and JLM
for 1 and then we'll have our angle
which for now we've been using degrees
so we'll keep using degrees so it will
just revert it to radians here this will
be our angle I believe what do I call it
no it's just rotation we should call
this angle in degrees or something like
that to not be confusing obviously and
then the axis of course is going to be
the z-axis here and then we have our
scale which is just going to be this
size essentially so we have a vector
size here we'll grab that and this will
be GLM that's for one point zero and
then this will be let's say size dot X
size dot Y and then one so what i'll
scaling does that access ok cool that's
our transform now what we need to do is
multiply this with each of the vertices
that make up this quad now we don't have
vertices and since we're going to need
these vertices for everything right
we're going to need them for every
drawing function I'm actually going to
create them inside this init function so
if we take a look at what the vertices
are gonna look like let's do it maybe
it doesn't really matter where you do
this I might actually do this at the end
and we might talk about reordering it in
the future
but basically air starter dot will say
quadrant vertices we're gonna have four
vertices here let's go and make them so
let's say quad vertex well we don't
really care about that they're going to
be the position the vertex positions so
maybe over here I'll just add them to
the end this is basically just going to
be GLM Veck for we're gonna make them
beg for is just so they're easy to
multiply with the mat floors without
having to convert them or anything like
that
and we'll call them quad vertex
positions okay and then we'll have
obviously four of these so that's that's
that and then if we come over here
so a quad vertex positions zero we can
set them up so this is going to be
negative 0.5 negative 0.5 0 for said and
then one point zero for y and then we're
going to repeat this obviously for each
of our vertices and we're just kind of
drawing a quad where zero is the origin
it's gonna have a size of one by one
and we're just gonna go clockwise so
this will be positive this will be
positive and then these two will be
positive as well pretty simple stuff
okay cool so taking that into account
now if we want to draw something then
it's going to be as simple as coming
down over here we have our transform we
just need to do quad position for vertex
positions zero and we want to multiply
our transform with that so transform
times that and that's it really the only
thing the change is here is going to be
which quad posit quad vertex position we
access so transform two and then
transform three I'll go write the quad
vertex positions three all right zero
one two three looks pretty good to me so
now we should have rotation and
everything should be good let's test
this out now obviously we have to do it
for that for everything else but we'll
do it for this first so if I come over
here we had I think example a dozen all
right is that sandbox 2d is what we're
talking about
let me bring that back so we had a
rotated quad what I'll do is I'll
actually we've got this mini
checkerboard texture that we're drawing
with a tiling factor of 20 I'm gonna try
and rotate that so I think rotations the
third parameter so what I'll do is well
we need to call draw rotate accordance
that reward and then maybe like 45
degrees that should be easy to see so
let's hit f5 let's see what happens this
should be 45 now I do have a weird
offset here because remember we've
changed the origin now the origin is now
the middle of the coordinate the bottom
left corner which I think is better so
if we wanted it to be completely rotated
around the origin
let's try zero zero everywhere and then
we'll yeah we'll leave it as a size of
one and there we go you can see it's
perfectly rotated around the origin and
then a really quick way to make sure
we're doing everything in the right
order and everything is just to just you
know we'll translate a negative two and
then try the rotation and because that
sentence I just had made like no sense
what I meant was we want to make sure
that work you know rotating the quad
around its origin not around the origin
of the world and if you do your matrix
multiplications at the wrong order then
it's going to apply that rotation to
something else so it's important to test
that as well okay cool
there we go that's done let's do
everything else now so the way that this
is gonna work is we're going to use
these quad vertex positions everywhere
and we're also going to use this
transform everywhere now obviously a
transform you know for something like
let's let's start at the beginning so
transform for this is super simple right
all it really is going to be is just a
translation and a scale you again like
we could generate new vertices and then
we wouldn't need either of these but to
be kind of I guess uniform across the
board where you're just gonna do
everything this way so yes this was kind
of a spontaneous decision but I'm sure
it's gonna be fine and I think that it's
going to make the code look a little bit
more I don't know
balanced it's gonna make the car look
the same which is gonna be good
all right so filling this out now at
this point you know you could you know
like these are gonna be the same
everywhere they're on one right so we
could technically just um
you know we're getting to the point
where since these are all the same and
these are like look look up a bull will
say like they're predictable and they're
basically the same I mean they're for
different values but they're the same
for each quad we could just convert this
into a for loop that iterates through
and gets all the data and I don't know
we might do this in like the next
revision but for now we'll just leave it
like this okay so we have the transform
with old quad vertex positions and then
this is yep okay great so moving on this
is our draw quad with a texture so again
what I'll do is I'll copy the transform
and you'll note this of course is not
the rotated quad it's just a regular
quad and then we'll just grab this and
we should be good let's copy all of this
stuff
whoops three two one zero
this just feels like I'm programming
normally doesn't even feel like a video
to be honest so I'm not going too fast
for you guys I'm just literally going as
fast as I can because I'm gonna have
time for dinner
if I don't okay anyway so personal
problems aside we have this size and
rotation okay so we have this function
that is a color that's rotated okay so
to do that I mean we'll basically just
take this I guess because we haven't
converted this at all and this was just
a transform with a rotation and yeah
it's pretty much the same so I'll grab
this including the transform this was
our rotated draw rotated quad textured
right we'll grab that we'll paste that
into here and then so we had a texture
index this should be the same as what we
used for the white texture and I don't
think it has a tiling factor does it no
that's showing up as red as well so
we'll we'll copy and paste those here so
that we have a text index and maybe I
should have called a texture index well
it doesn't matter okay and I think
everything else is gonna be good so we
have translation rotation scale but this
is now for a rotated quad that is a
color let's delete this old path
situation and we can I'm sure we can
clean up
some of the other stuff but let's test
it first so we'll have a rotated quad
here now you'll see that this takes in
radians now we changed it to taking
degrees so yeah I mean we should
probably take in radians because that
way it moves the responsibility of
converting into radians to the client
rather than the than always having to do
it and anyway it's probably better that
way but for now we might leave it like
this let's see so yeah so we're
representing this what is this this is
some kind of like red quad this rotated
let's move it in the positive
x-direction and then everything else is
going to be a little bit weird remember
because we used to be the bottom left
corner used to be like the Anchor Point
I guess or the origin for for these now
it's moved okay so yeah we have a
rotated quad looks pretty good to me
maybe let's add a little bit of
animation so we'll say static fluid
rotation equals zero then rotation plus
equals time step times like 20 or
something on an urn and then what we'll
do is we'll set the rotation here so the
checkerboard texture should now rotate I
guess we could have made the quad do it
as well but yeah there we go so this is
rotating all right it looks good and we
can actually probably make that times 50
or something all right and then what
else do I want to do so the background
which was I don't even know what the
background was is the big one
so what's the big one what ten by ten so
it's got to be this one yeah let's see
the cool thing is now since we've kind
of and we can just I guess we could just
do feel I'm back three zero the cool
thing here is that since zero is the
origin everything you know we we can
draw this as zero we don't need to like
calculate how big it is and then offset
it by half that amount
none of that stuff we can just rotate it
normally or rather we can just position
it normally which is going to be nice
all right cool and then we've lost our
other one which is arts because I set
that to zero what was it at before it
was negative zero point one I can't
let's leave it at that because of the
whole you know Zed kind of sorting
situation all right and there we have
this all right cool and then we've got
that as well so that looks pretty cool
now we've got everything
working correctly with rotation in batch
rendering everything that you see being
drawn there of course is one draw call
which is what we want now what I want to
do is make a quick pass on this just to
clean it up because I don't think we
need everything dewy like we used to
have I guess we still do though like we
used to have you know a quad vertex
array and but we still have that it's
just we use it we've repurposed it sorry
maybe there is not much cleanup to do
maybe everything is good yeah I guess
I'll just leave it like this one thing I
might do is for a name text index to now
I guess I should be if anything I should
be more verbose
so we'll say texture index we'll just
make sure it's called texture index
everywhere using visual assist here yeah
that's it I don't know what else to do I
think that's it I think we've done
everything we set out to do a little bit
of a quick episode for a chain which is
nice but yeah there we go was whether
rotated quad obviously it's rotations
working now it's all still drawn in one
drop all and performance is well at the
very least it's above 60 fps and shows a
lot more than that but um that brings me
to my next kind of thing and that is the
fact that now that we've got this batch
render this capable of rendering well
everything that we were rendering
previously but now back together into
one Drupal we should probably do some
kind of performance profiling and see
first of all what the performance is
like I would live would love to get some
like frame counters and stuff like that
on the screen I also want to get some
statistics and maybe some controls for
the renderer so that we can you know
maybe stress test it that's another
thing that I want to do I want to design
some kind of stress test for this but
then I also want to control the size of
the batch so I want to be able to say
hey can you please make the batch ten
thousand like we've done but we've done
that as like a static constant I want
that to be variable I want the renderer
to be able to adapt to that and we also
need to test all the kind of edge cases
so to speak they don't really edge cases
but stuff like um you know what happens
if we render more than thirty two
textures what happens if I don't know we
read them more than what we've allowed
in a single batch does it successfully
start a new batch and
does it render properly stuff like that
we need to basically make this into a
little bit of a batch rendering
playground to make sure that first of
all everything works but also I am
interested in like the performance
metrics and stuff like that so that is
the plan hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please hit that like
button patreon like home for such the
Cherno is the best place to help support
me and this channel and this series and
hazel and everything like that
I've been live-streaming there every
single week apartment this week but
check that out you can also watch the
streams after they've been streamed so
on demand and there's like probably over
six hours of streams at the moment
available tube and I've just been
developing hazel Deb the stuff that you
guys saw I also made a video if you
haven't check it out it's um the whole
kind of hazel 3d environment Maps and
the HDR stuff that I've been doing for
that that was completely live stream so
you can if you want to see how I did
that and how I implemented that then
patreon home force Ashley Turner and
you'll be able to watch those streams
back and see how the amazing process of
making all of that anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed this video
stay safe love you all goodbye
[Music]